all right switching gears now they're
calling it the great resignation workers
leaving the workplace in droves because
they're burnt out in fact one survey
found 41 percent of workers are
considering quitting or changing
professions a new study printed in the
journal nature human behavior
found that since the pandemic we are
working 10 percent longer work weeks
part of that is because with so many
people working from home the lines have
really been blurred between that work
time and the at-home time and that is
contributing to exhaustion
so what can you do about it we asked
denisha mingo who runs mhs behavioral
services here in the valley and she says
it's important to let your bosses know
how you're feeling
and let them know what's going on so
that maybe they can try to provide some
internal support whether it's through
eap or
i don't know if it's a possibility of
hiring or changing the workload or even
giving you a little bit of diversity in
your work scheduling your work load so
that you don't get so overwhelmed
some other tips she had you know you got
to make time for those breaks even if
that means leaving the house or the
office you have to do it put down your
phone close your laptop perhaps find
something to distract your brain from
work during those critical off times
even if it's you know five or ten
minutes
can make a difference yeah it really can
i mean we've been seeing this you know
with mental health coming out to the
forefront where people are able to talk
about it but it is a problem and the
pandemics seem to exacerbate the issue
yeah i think there's a lot of burnout
going on i know one good thing we have
here at the station we see
people get out and they just walk the
parking lot just to get a change of
scenery and get some steps in get some
steps in that's good too yeah now when
it's warm outside it's a little harder
to do but it is you've just got to
change your environment even if it's
just for a few minutes when you talked
about phone addiction but at the same
time if you're looking at the phone
completely separate than all the work
stuff just play a little game yeah do
something to distract yourself and you
know i thought about this almost setting
an alarm in my phone to remind me to get
up and do something oh yeah otherwise
you just you know you tune in and you're
working hard and all of a sudden the
day's gone by
and then you get up and go oh wow
too long we wouldn't know anything about
that my legs have atrophied here